here's a story ready for this one yeah
okay so this guy on my dating app said
he was the quarterback for the Los
Angeles Rams oh okay keep keep talking
so I wrote to him and I was like oh my
God I went to the first practice game I
was so frustrated being a a girl from
Los Angeles who loves football and like
we didn't have any teams and then I
moved away to New York and then we got
two teams and um it's nice to meet you
my name is Drew he was not the
quarterback for the LA
he's a musician that thought he was
being
cute okay I just how should I feel about
this you should feel uh lied to robbed I
had a fantasy that you're like the new
Taylor Swift and you'd be at the games
right